so where i left off we had this infinite
this infinite plate it's just an
infinite plane and it's a charge plate
with the charge density sigma and we
what we did is we said okay well we have
some you know we're taking this point up
here that's h units above the surface of
our charge plate and we wanted to figure
out the the electric field at that point
generated by a ring of radius r
essentially centered you know at the
base
of above
the base of where that point is above
we want to figure out what is the
electric field generated by this ring at
that point
and we figured out that well the
electric field was
this
and then
because we made a symmetry argument in
the last video we only care about the y
component because we figured out the
electric field generated from any point
the x components cancel out because if
we have a point here
it will have some x component field the
field x component might be in that
direction to the right then you have
another point out here and its x
component will just cancel it out so we
only compare care about the y component
so
at the end we meticulously
calculated what the y component of the
electric field generated by the ring is
at h units above the surface
so with that out of the way let's see if
we can
sum up a bunch of rings going from
radius infinity to radius 0
and figure out the total
y component or essentially the total
electric field because we realize that
all the x's cancel out anyway the total
electric field at that point h units
above the surface of the
of the plane so let me erase
a lot of this just so i can
free it up for some hardcore math
this is pretty much all calculus at this
point so let me erase all of this watch
the previous video if you forgot how it
was derived
and let me even erase that because i
think i will need a lot of space
there you go
okay so let me let me redraw a little
bit just so we never forget what we what
we're doing here because that's easy to
that happens
so that's my plane
goes off in every direction
i have my point above the plane where
we're trying to figure out the electric
field and we've come to the conclusion
that the field is going to point upward
so we only care about the y component
it's h units above
the surface
it's h units above the surface and we're
figuring out the electric field
generated by a ring around that that
this point of radius r
and what's its y the y component of that
electric field we figured out it was
this
so now what we're going to do is take
the integral so the total electric field
from the plate
so
the total electric field is going to be
the integral
from our that's a really ugly looking
integral
from
a radius of zero to a radius of infinity
so we're going to take a sum of all of
the rings starting with the radius of
zero all the way to the ring that has a
radius of infinity because it's an
infinite plane so we're figuring out the
impact of the entire plane
taught
to take the sum of every ring so at the
the charge of or the field generated by
every ring and this is the field
generated by each of the rings
so it's let me do a different color this
light blue is getting a little
monotonous
k
h
2 pi
sigma
r
d r
over
h squared plus r squared to the three
halves
now let's simplify this a little bit
let's take some constants out of it just
so this looks like a slightly a simpler
equation so this equals
the integral from 0 to an oh whoops
i didn't want to write that just yet so
let's take the k i'm going to leave the
2 there and you'll see why in a second
but i'm going to take all the other
constants out that we're not integrating
across so it's equal to k
h
pi sigma
pi
sigma
times the integral
from 0 to infinity
of what is this so what did i what did i
leave in there i left a 2r
so we could rewrite this as
well actually i'm running out of space
but let me it's 2r
dr
over
h squared
plus r
squared to the three halves or we could
think of it as the negative three halves
right and so what's the the
antiderivative of here well this is
essentially the reverse chain rule
right i could make a substitution here
if you're more comfortable using the
substitution rule but
you might be able to eyeball this at
this point we could make the
substitution that
let me pick a good color we could make
the substation that u is equal to
if we just want to figure out the
antiderivative of this if u is equal to
h squared plus r squared h is just a
constant right
then
d u
is just equal to i mean d the the d u d
r right d u d r
is just this is a constant so it equals
two r
or we could say d u
is equal to two r
d r
and so if we're trying to take the
antiderivative
if we're trying to take the
antiderivative of
two r
d r
over
h squared plus r squared
to the three halves this is the exact
same thing as taking the anti-derivative
with this substitution two r d r we just
show right here the same thing as d u
right
so that's d u
over and then this is just u right a
squared plus r squared is u that we do
that by definition so u to the three
halves
which is equal to the antiderivative of
we could write this as u to the minus
three halves
d u and now that's easy this is just
kind of reverse
i guess you would call it the exponent
rule so that equals
minus 2
u
to the
minus one half and we can confirm right
if we take the derivative of this minus
one half times minus two is
one
and then subtract from one from here we
get minus three halves and then we could
add plus c but since we are eventually
going to do a definite integral the c's
all cancel out
or we could say that this is equal to
since we made that substitution
this equals minus 2
over we could say you know to minus 1
half that's the same thing as over the
square root of
h squared
plus r squared
right so all of the stuff i did in
magenta was just to figure out the
anti-derivative of this and we figured
it out to be this minus 2
over
8 squared plus
over the square root of h squared plus r
squared so with that out of the way
let's continue evaluating
our definite integral
so this expression simplifies to
this is a marathon problem but
satisfying
k
let's get all the constants k
h
pi
sigma
we can even take this minus 2 out let's
take this times
times
2.
and all of that and we're going to
evaluate the definite integral at the
the two boundaries
one over
the square root of h squared plus r
squared
evaluated
at infinity minus it evaluated at zero
right
well what is what does this expression
equal
well when you what is 1 over the square
root of 8 squared plus infinity right
what happens when we evaluate r at
infinity well
the square root of infinity is still
infinity and 1 over infinity is 0. so
this expression right here becomes 0.
when you evaluate it at infinity this
becomes zero
minus
this expression evaluated at zero
so what happens when it's at zero when r
squared is zero we get one over the
square root of h squared right
so let's let's write it all out this
becomes minus 2
k
h
pi
sigma
times 0 minus 1 over the square root of
h squared well this equals
minus
k
h
pi
sigma
times
well 1 over the square root of h squared
that's just 1 over h right and there's a
minus times minus one over h
well this minus and that minus cancel
out fair enough
and then this h and this one over h
should cancel out fair enough
and all we're left with after doing all
of that work and i'll do it in a bright
color because we've done a lot of work
to get here
is 2
k
pi
sigma
so that's neat on a lot of levels
first of all what do we even do here we
might have gotten lost in the math
this is the net electric field the total
electric field
at a point at height h
above this infinitely uniform this
infinite plate that has a uniform charge
and the charge density is sigma
but notice this this is the electric
field at that point but there's no h in
here so it essentially is telling us
that there's no the the the strength of
the field is in no way dependent on how
high above the field we are which tells
us is going to be a constant field we
can be anywhere above the plate and the
charge will be the same the only thing
sorry not the charge the field will be
the same the only thing that and and if
we have a test charge the force would be
the same
and the only thing that the strength of
the field or the strength of the exerted
electrostatic force is dependent on is
the charge density right this is
coulomb's constant pi is pi two pi
and i think it's kind of cool that it
involves pi but that's something else to
to ponder but all it matters all that
matters is the charge density
so hopefully you found that reasonably
satisfying and the big thing that we
learned here is that if i have an
infinite uniformly charged plate the
field you know and i put
i'm some distance h above that field you
know above that i keep mixing up words
above that plate it doesn't matter what
that h is i could be here i could be
here i could be here at all of those
points the field has the exact same
strength or the net electrostatic force
on a test charge at those points has the
exact same strength and that's kind of a
neat thing
and now if if you do believe everything
that occurred in the last two videos you
can now um believe that uh we have that
there are such things as uniform
electric fields and they occur between
parallel plates especially far away from
the boundaries
see you soon